Mary Harrington calls that the law of
FAP entropy which is whatever you start
out walking to will get progressively
more intense over time beautiful yeah
since the goal is emotional engagement
how does a platform keep you emotionally
engaged they do it by serving up more
extreme content so if you look at your
platform algorithms if there's certain
things that you search for it'll serve
you like tons of extreme stuff in that
way so if you watch one cute cat video
then you need to see cats doing cuter
things to stay on the platform we see
this with Fe usage as well where they're
a gradual like movement towards hardcore
use because you require more stimulus to
your eyes and ears and things like that
to get that same level of arousal and
then if you have sexual relations with a
regular human being the stimulus is just
different the framing in the story that
you tell yourself around your upon use
is massively contributing to what is
going to happen out the other side of it